BARBARA IMPERIALI: Now,
I want to talk today
about one small thing before
we move on to signaling,
because it really
kind of completes
the work that we talked about
with respect to trafficking.
So I popped this
question up last time,
and it seemed like there weren't
quite enough sort of people
leaping to give me an answer.
But let's just take a look
at the big picture of things,
as it's always good to do.
Because this will also
get me to one other topic,
which is protein misfolding.
So at the end of
the day, what really
defines where a protein
is, what it does,
is defined by its sequence.
But you always want to remember
that a protein sequence is
defined by its messenger.
The messenger is defined
by the pre-messenger.
Yes, there may be splicing
events that really
cause changes in localization.
But the pre-messenger
includes the content.
And then what defines
that is the DNA.
There's certain
aspects of regulation
at the epigenetic level that
we don't talk about barely
in this course.
But I want you to make
sure that you realize
at the end of the day,
what the protein is,
how it folds, is
defined originally
by the sequence of the DNA,
although a long way along here.
The post-translational
modifications that we started
talking about last time
are defined by the protein
sequence, which all the
way is defined by the DNA--
so, so much of protein function.
And there's one more
aspect of proteins
that's defined by
the DNA sequence,
and that's whether a protein
folds well, or perhaps,
in some cases, misfolds.
And that's the thing I want to
talk about very briefly today.
Because I think that this
captures the picture.
So let's just go over here
and write misfolded proteins,
which, just like
everything else,
largely end up being
dictated by the DNA.
Because whether a
protein folds faithfully
into a good
structure or misfolds
can be a function of
the protein sequence.
So there could be mutations
in the protein that ultimately
end up that the protein
misfolds and forms
either a misfolded tertiary
structure, or even worse,
adopts an aggregated form
that causes a lot of damage
within cells and
outsides of cells.
So I want to talk just briefly
about the processes that we
have-- it's just one slide--
to deal with misfolded proteins.
So when a protein is
translated, it almost
starts folding straight away,
especially large proteins.
A fair amount of a protein
may have already emerged
from the ribosome and
started folding, even
when the whole
protein isn't made.
The sequence ultimately ends you
up with a well-folded protein.
But if the protein does
not fold fast enough,
or there is a mistake
in this, which
might be caused intrinsically
by the primary sequence,
if there's a mistake in that--
so slow folding or
incorrect folding--
then you will end up with a
protein that's partially folded
within the context of a cell.
We especially encounter
misfolded proteins
when we are
overexpressing proteins
in cells, because you're just
making one of a type of protein
really quickly, and it
doesn't have a chance
to adopt its faithful structure.
So there are proteins
within the cell that
helped sort of protect
the folding process early
on, to allow the protein to have
enough time in singular, not
with a lot of copies of itself
around that are misfolded,
to adopt a folded structure.
And these proteins
are called chaperones.
I don't know if you guys
are familiar with the term
chaperone.
It was a term that
was heavily used
in the sort of 18th
and 19th century.
A chaperone used to be
an aunt or someone who
you would send out with your
beautiful young daughter
to chaperone her, to protect
her so she didn't get bothered
by those mean men out there.
So chaperones were-- that
was the original definition
of the chaperone.
And it's kind of interesting
that the chaperones are now
proteins that help folding or
protect against misfolding.
How do they do this?
Generally, a protein
will fold poorly
if it's very, very-- if
it's quite hydrophobic.
And hydrophobic patches
are exposed in aggregate.
So let's say, you
have a protein,
and there's a lot of copies,
but they're not folded.
If you have things that are
hydrophobic that would normally
end up tucked
inside the protein,
if the protein hasn't
folded in its good time,
these will just start
to form aggregates, sort
of associating with each other.
It's just a physical phenomenon.
If you put something that's
got a lot of hydrophobic faces
on the outside, this
will start forming
an aggregated bundle, and not
a nicely folded protein at all.
What the chaperones
may do is in part
hold the partially
folded protein.
So let's just think of this
big jelly bean as a chaperone
until things start to
adopt a favorable state.
But sometimes it's
just too much.
The chaperone cannot
handle the flux of protein.
So the protein ends up being
recognized as misfolded.
And then it gets tagged
as a misfolded protein,
and it gets taken to a place
in the cell for disposal.
So if you are unable to fold,
there is a tagging process.
And I mentioned it last time.
It's a process known
as ubiquitination.
This is also a
post-translational
modification, but
it's one that occurs
on poorly folded proteins.
And I'm going to describe
to you that system,
because the ubiquitination
is the flag, the signal,
or the tag, to take this
protein to the great shredder,
basically.
And so what does the--
what's a paper shredder--
I like the analogy
with a paper shredder.
So here's a fellow who's got
too much on in his inbox.
So he just sends it
straight to the shredder.
It's a little bit about too much
misfolded protein being made.
So instead of sort of waiting
to deal with the paperwork,
you just send it
straight to the shredder.
And the proteasome is
the cellular shredder
that actually breaks proteins
up into small chunks,
and then digests them out.
So think of the
proteasome as a shredder,
which chops up proteins
into small pieces,
mostly into short
peptides that are 8 to 14
amino acids in length--
fairly small.
Short peptides won't cause
a problem in aggregation,
and will then be
further digested.
Now, if you've got this shredder
sitting around in the cell,
it's like having a paper
shredder on all the time.
You've got a-- there's a risk
things may end up in there
without meaning to be.
So for things to be
tagged for shredding,
they go through what's known
as the ubiquitin system.
So the first thing
to get into that is--
and it's only then
that proteins are
tagged for shredding up or
chopping up by the proteasome.
So as you can sort
of tell by its name,
it's got protease
function, but it's
a large, macromolecular
protease,
with lots and lots
of subunits that
are important to cut that
polypeptide into smaller
pieces.
But because many
of your proteins
may be partially
folded or misfolded,
they first have to be unfolded.
So the ubiquitin is the
signal to send proteins
to the proteasome, where
the second action is
protease activity, and the
first action is unfolding.
So what I show you
on this picture
is the barrel structure
of a proteasome.
Let me explain the
components of it.
The red component
of the proteasome
is a multimeric ring
that uses ATP and starts
tugging apart the protein
that you need to destroy.
But it will only do
that if the protein
becomes labeled for destruction
by the ubiquitin system.
And I am showing you here a
massively simplified version.
Let's say this is a
misfolded protein.
It gets tagged with
another protein.
It's a really little
protein known as ubiquitin.
I've shown you the
three-dimensional structure
here.
And using ATP, you
end up managing
to put a ubiquitin chain
on the protein that's
going to be destroyed.
That is a post-translational
modification that
is a tagging for destruction.
If the protein is
not tagged, then it's
not going to be chewed up.
That makes sense.
You don't want to be
chopping up proteins
in a cell with wild abandon.
Once the ubiquitin
chain is on here,
the protein will bind
to the unfoldase part
of the proteasome,
and with ATP, it
will just stop tugging the rest
of the residual structure apart
to thread the protein down into
the blue part of the barrel.
It's a little hard
to see it like this,
but it's literally,
the proteasome,
are four concentric rings.
Let me see.
I hope my artwork is
going to be good enough.
Well, that's an unfoldase.
And so is that.
And then in the center,
there is a protease.
And each of these
components is multimeric,
having six or seven subunits.
So it's a huge structure.
It has a sedimentation
coefficient
of 20S, that entire structure.
I don't know if you remember
when I talked about ribosomes,
they were so big we didn't tend
to talk about them by size.
We talked about them by
sedimentation coefficient.
And the large and small
subunits of the ribosome,
the eukaryotic one, just to
remind you, were 40S and 60S.
So just remember that
S stands for Svedberg.
It's a sedimentation
coefficient unit.
It describes how fast
approaching precipitates.
So once the protein has
been labeled with ubiquitin,
it binds to the unfoldase.
And then the single strand feeds
into the center core, which
is two sections of protease.
So it's feeding in here.
It sees the protease activity.
And then it's just
short pieces of protein
are spit out of the proteasome.
Once these are really
little pieces of peptide,
they're readily digested by
proteases within the cell.
And you can recycle
the amino acids,
or you can do other things with
these small pieces of peptide.
They actually end up sometimes
being sent for presentation
on the surface of the
cell by the immune system.
And you may hear a little
bit more about that later.
So the proteasome--
oh, I apologize--
this should have been 26S--
has a molecular weight
that's very large--
2,000 kilodaltons.
That's why we refer to it by
its sedimentation coefficient.
So this machinery
is very important
to get rid of misfolded
or aggregated proteins
to destroy them.
Now, does-- are people aware of
the sorts of diseases that can
result from misfolded proteins?
Has anyone been
reading the news much
about certain types of diseases,
particularly in neurobiology?
Anyone aware of those?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Was it
mad cow disease?
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Which one?
AUDIENCE: Mad cow.
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Yes.
Mad cow.
So there are a variety of
neurological disorders,
and mad cow is one of them.
Creutz U-T-Z feldt-Jakob.
But Alzheimer's
disease is another one.
Pick's disease is another.
There are a wide variety
of neurological disorders
that result from misfolded
proteins, both inside the cell
and in the extracellular matrix,
forming these tangles that
are toxic to the neurons,
causing them to no longer
function, and then
resulting in many
of these neurological disorders.
The ones I've described to you,
I've mentioned to you here.
I know many of you are familiar
with Alzheimer's disease.
Mad cow disease is a variant of
a particular protein misfolding
disease that was
first noted in cattle.
And they basically just
fell down, dropped down.
And it was in some
cases ascribed to--
the contagion with the disease
is ascribed not to a virus
or to a microorganism,
but literally,
to misfolded proteins
causing the formation
of more misfolded proteins.
So these are all collectively
designated as prion diseases.
I think you'll have
read that term.
And it's a particular
kind of disease
that the infectious agent
isn't a living system--
not a virus, not a
microbe, a fungus,
a protozoan, but
rather a protein,
where it's misfolded
structure nucleates
the formation of more
misfolded structure
that leads to the disease.
So I grew up in England
during the years
where there was a lot of
mad cow disease in England.
And even though I'm a vegetarian
in the US for 30 years,
I can't give blood in the US,
because I lived in England
during the time when there
was a lot of mad cow disease.
And this can be dormant
for a long, long time
before it suddenly takes over.
So there's restrictions on
blood donation in certain cases.
And it's because
it's not something
you can treat with
an antibiotic,
you can treat with an antiviral.
It's literally traces
of badly folded protein
that can nucleate the formation
of more badly folded protein,
that can lead to the diseases.
These were-- there's
particular instances of some
of these diseases in
tribes where there's
pretty serious
cannibalism, and eating
your sort of senior
relative's brains
was considered to be something--
an important act of respect.
And there was this
transfer of some
of these prion-type diseases
through cannibalism as well.
So eating contaminated
meat, be it a cow,
be it your
grandparents, whatever,
it's something that
actually is-- it's
a serious transmissible disease.
And it's really--
in the situations
where it can be sort of related
back to contaminated meat are
one thing.
But there are variations in
the case of Alzheimer's, where
the sequence of proteins may
dictate that they don't fold
well, or they're not
post-translationally modified
properly, so they end up
as misfolded proteins.
So these are often
genetically linked disorders,
some of the things
like Alzheimer's.
And once again, remember
that goes all the way back
to the DNA, which
might, in some cases,
trigger the misfolded disease.
So it's a fascinating area,
and there's a tremendous amount
to be studied.
Because of the aging population,
these diseases are piling up,
and we need to mitigate
the causes of the disease,
and find ways, for
example, to slow down.
If there are these fibrils of
protein that are misfolded,
can we maybe inhibit
that formation
with some kind of small
molecule inhibitor
to mitigate the
symptoms of the disease?
So it's a very,
very active area,
because almost every-- many,
many neurological disorders
seem to be coming down
to misfolded proteins.
So let's move on
now to signaling.
All right.
So we're going to
spend two lectures
on-- the remainder of this
lecture plus the next lecture.
And what I want to
do in this lecture
is introduce you to some of the
paradigms, the nuts and bolts,
the mechanics of
protein signaling.
And then in the
next lecture, I'm
going to show you
examples of how
all the characteristics
that we define signaling by
get represented in signaling
pathways within cells.
So I'm going to give you
all the moving parts,
and then we'll move forward to
see how the moving parts might
function in a physiological
action, such as a response
to something particularly
scary, or as a trigger to do--
for the cells to do
something different.
So let me take
you, first of all,
to a cartoon-like
image of a cell.
And we're going to just
take from the very simplest
beginning.
But then this topic will get
quite complex, as you see.
But that's why I think
it's important to reduce
the process of protein signaling
down to simple aspects of it
that we can really
recognize, even in much
more complicated pathways.
So in protein
cellular signaling,
this is a complex
system of communication
that governs all basic
activities of the cell.
There are no cells that
don't do signaling.
Bacteria and
eukaryotic cells may do
signaling slightly differently.
But they still do have an
integrated correlated system
that's responsible
for triggering
functions of the cell through
a series of discrete steps.
So protein signaling
can be dissected
into three basic steps,
where you, first of all,
receive a signal.
And we're going to talk
about what that signal is.
What's the nature
of that signal,
is it small molecule,
large molecule?
Where is the signal?
Where does it act?
Then the next step is
to transduce the signal.
And finally, you have an
outcome, which is a response.
So we're going to talk about
each of these components
in order to understand flux
through cellular signaling
pathways, and how
they work to give you
a rapid response to
a necessary signal.
All right.
So in this cartoon, let's just,
for example, think about what
if we want to trigger
cell division?
We might have a signal, which
is the yellow molecule--
a small molecule,
large molecule.
We'll get to that later.
There's a cell here, where
on the surface of the cell
is a receptor.
And that would be the entity
that receives the signal.
So in the first
step in the process,
there's a buildup of a
concentration of a signal.
And it occupies the
receptors on the surface
of the cell, and in some
cases, inside the cell.
We'll talk about a
bifurcation there.
But really, a lot of
cellular signaling
is dominated by cells
coming-- by signals
coming from outside the cell.
What happens upon this binding
event is the transduction.
If you bind to something
on the outside of the cell,
as a consequence, you might
have a change on that structure.
If it crosses the
membrane, you might
have a change on that same
molecule structure that's
on the inside of the cell.
So that's why it's
called transduction.
You're transducing
a soluble signal
from outside, binding that
signal to the cell surface
receptor.
And the cell surface receptor
is responding in some way.
And there are two
principle ways in which
we respond to
extracellular signals,
and we'll cover them both.
The next event that
might happen is
through the change that
happens to the intracellular
component of the receptor.
There might be a
change, a binding event,
another step occur
within the cell.
And as a function of
that, you get a response.
All right?
So it's really-- thinking
it in these three components
is a good way to
kind of dissect out
the beginnings of
the complication.
And then what
we'll be able to do
is really start to see what
kinds of molecules come in?
How are they received?
How is the signal transduced?
And what's the ultimate outcome
with respect to a response?
Everyone OK with that?
All right.
Now this is what you
have to look forward to.
So we give you something
with three moving parts,
and suddenly we show
you something with sort
of, you know, 100 moving parts.
And cell biologists
very, very frequently
look at these maps
of cells, where
what they're
looking at with each
of these sort of little
acronyms or names, all of these
are proteins, where they
have been mapped out
through cell biology and
cellular biochemistry
to be existing in certain
components of the cell.
And what has also been
mapped out very frequently
is, who talks to who?
So the fact that JAK S
might interact with STAT 35
and so on.
So much of this was worked
out through cell biology
and biochemistry,
and also by genetics.
So Professor Martin
has talked to you
about identifying a player in
a complex system by genetics.
Let's say you have a cell
that fails to divide.
You might perhaps screen
or divides unevenly,
or has some defect
in cell division.
You might be able to pick
out a particular player.
Now, the key thing I want to
point out to you with this cell
is what's on the
outside of the cell
and runs across the
membrane, and might
have the chance,
the opportunity,
to have both an extracellular
receptor and an intracellular
function.
And those key proteins are
things like receptor tyrosine
kinases.
And we're going to talk about
all of these in a moment.
G protein-coupled receptors,
and various other cell surface
receptors--
so all of these--
anything that spans a
membrane has the opportunity
to be an important component
of a signaling pathway.
Because what you're
routinely trying to do
is have your signal recognized
on the outside of the cell
by something that
spans the membrane.
The signal will bind to that.
And then you will have an
intracellular response.
So that's breaking it down.
That's why proteins
that are made
through the secretory
pathway that we talked
about in the last
lecture, that go
through that
endomembrane system,
and end up being parked
in the plasma membrane
are so important.
Other proteins that actually get
secreted through that pathway
are also important.
What do you think they
may be important for?
Let's say you've made a
protein within the cell.
It goes through all the system.
It doesn't stay parked
in the cell membrane.
It actually gets
released from the cell.
What might that be doing?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Yeah.
Exactly.
So that endomembrane
system that I
described to you, that pathway
is great for making receivers.
And it's great for
making signals.
And that's really what can sort
of fuel the functions of cells.
OK.
So in systems biology, you
may have heard this term
quite frequently.
Systems biology is
research that helps
us understand the underlying
structure of signaling
networks.
So a lot of people who
have common interests
in engineering, computational
analysis and cell biology,
might bring in
data to allow them
to make models of
cellular systems,
to understand flux through
signaling pathways.
So they may make
fundamental measurements
about the concentrations of
some components within the cell.
And then try to say, OK,
I know based on everything
I've measured that this is
a dominant pathway for gene
regulation.
And I could control this
pathway by different--
by sort of different
types of interactions.
In this cellular system, I also
show you another component,
which is the nucleus.
And when we discuss and
describe specific cell
signaling networks,
in some cases
the signaling
network may involve
receiving a signal, undergoing
a variety of changes
in the cytoplasm, but
then a change that
eventually results in a
protein going to the nucleus.
And oftentimes, those proteins
that run into the nucleus
are transcription factors that
then trigger DNA replication
or transcription.
And then promote activities.
So this is how you
think about it.
When you think of cellular
signaling, it's really about,
what does the signal need to do?
And what's the pathway
that I follow to get there?
So all of those are
membrane proteins.
So now let's look at
the canonical aspects
of signal transduction.
So the first-- and I'm going to
rely on these little cartoons.
But I want, both in this
lecture and the next,
to really show you where these
recur in so many systems.
So to that purpose, I want to
talk about the characteristics.
So the first critical
characteristic
is a signal and
it's specificity.
So a signal will
be something that
comes from outside of the cell.
It could be a hormone that's
produced in the hypothalamus
and sent to another organ.
But the most important
thing about the signal
is that that signal, which
binds to a receptor in a cell
membrane, is specific for
a particular receptor,
and the different signal won't
blind to the same receptor.
You have to have faithful
signal specificity
to trigger the right function.
So if it's a hormone, it's got
to be the hormone that you want
to trigger the receptor, not a
related but different-looking
structure.
If it's a small
protein, you want
it to be the exact one that
binds with high specificity
to a receptor.
So what that means is if
something is binding--
if a small molecule is
binding to a protein
on the surface of a cell
with high specificity
and high affinity, it means that
even at a low concentration,
it will make that
binding contact.
But all the other small
molecules that are around
won't crosstalk into that
triggering that interaction.
So we have high specificity,
and we gain that specificity
through macromolecular
interactions,
just like the ones we talked
about in biochemistry.
So if we have a small
molecule or a protein bind
to the receptor, it's making
all those hydrogen bonding,
electrostatic, noncovalent
types of interactions
with high specificity, so that a
low concentration of the signal
molecule is efficient for
binding to the receptor
to trigger the function.
The next characteristic
is amplification.
Now let's put some lines
between these guys.
Now, with all the
signaling pathways
that you're going
to see, we're going
to be looking where in a
pathway you get amplification.
Very commonly, you
might have a response
that's just the result of
a single molecule binding
a single receptor.
But at the end of the day, you
might want a large response.
You might want to
make a lot of ATP.
Or you might want to
replicate all of the genome.
So you need some kind of
amplification where in a sense
you're turning up the
volume on your signal.
And you need to do that rapidly.
So frequently in
signaling pathways,
you go through a
cascade of reactions
where the signal might
affect an enzyme.
But once you make
that enzyme active,
it might work on many, many
copies of another enzyme.
And then each of those may
work on even more copies.
So that's what I mean
by amplification,
where at some stage
you've generated
a molecule that can result
in the cascade of a reaction.
So we often refer to
these as cascades.
So if you're
Spanish-speaking, cascada.
You want to think about a
waterfall coming from just
a single molecule of water.
You're getting a large
increase in your signal
as a result of amplification.
The next feature or
characteristic of signaling
is feedback.
At the end of the day,
if you're signaling,
I got to make some ATP.
I got to run out of the woods.
I'm getting chased.
At a certain stage,
you need to stop
all of the process occurring.
So feedback is just a
negative feedback loop
that might slow down
some of those steps that
are involved in amplification.
So for a pathway, you only
want the pathway turned on
for a prescribed amount of time.
And then you want
to be able to say,
I'm done with that
whole pathway.
I don't need to keep churning
through all those enzymes.
It's time to stop that.
And that usually occurs
through negative feedback.
And remember, we talked
about negative feedback
when we were talking about
enzyme catalyzed pathways.
So feedback is very
often some kind
of negative feedback,
which suppresses
a series of
transformations, perhaps
through a product of those
transformations acting
as an inhibitor
on an early step.
And then finally,
the other component
of a signaling network--
if you think of
signaling networks
as electronic structures,
you have integration.
So that's the last
characteristic feature.
And let me go back
to that big circuit
diagram quickly to show you
an example of integration.
So if you look at this
signaling pathway,
all these signaling
steps are not single.
You just have a signal
come in, and you end up,
for example, in the nucleus.
But rather, other components
may have crosstalk
within one pathway,
and start out
either amplifying
or turning down
a particular signaling pathway.
So these are networks.
They're not pathways.
They're networks that
interact and communicate,
all to amplify signals
or turn down signals.
So integration is an
important part of signaling,
because you're often dealing
with the integrated function
of a number of pathways to
get a particular response.
And that actually ends up being
one of the situations where
sometimes a
particular enzyme may
look like a perfect target
for a therapeutic agent.
But if you don't take into
account the integration steps,
you may be trying
to deal with a--
you may think you're dealing
with a single pathway,
but you're, rather,
dealing with crosstalk
with a lot of other pathways.
And what often
happens in a cell is
there's compensation
from other pathways.
Is everybody following?
Any questions here about this?
So what I want
you to think about
is that it's just amazing
what is orchestrated
to have even the simplest
functions in the cell,
how many interacting
components there may be.
Specificity, amplification,
feedback, and integration--
all right, so let's talk
briefly about types of signals
and how we name them, where
they come from, in order
to make sure we're all on
the same page with respect
to the language that's used.
So now, signals may take
different molecular forms.
They may be small molecules,
for example, an amino acid
or a phospholipid--
just something little.
Alternatively, they
may be proteins.
They may be carbohydrates.
They might take
different forms in terms
of their molecular structure.
But we tend to describe signals
by where they come from.
So what I've shown
you here is a picture
from the book that
just describes how
we refer to certain signals.
So there are four
different terms--
autocrine, juxtacrine-- and I'm
going to just give you a little
hint to how to
remember these terms--
paracrine, endocrine.
OK.
So these don't tell you
anything about the molecule.
They tell you about
where it's come from.
So an autocrine
signal is a signal
that may come from a cell,
but it's signaling to itself.
So it may produce a
component that's released.
And so it's producing this
through a secretory pathway.
It's a release, and it stays
in the vicinity of the cell.
So the self is self-signaling.
So whenever you
see something auto,
you just want to
say, oh, that means
it's coming from the same
cell where the signal occurs.
Let's move to the next
one, which is paracrine.
I'm going to talk about jux--
and that's usually
from a nearby cell,
not a cell that's in contact--
definitely a different cell.
So paracrine is-- we
would always call nearby.
And endocrine is completely
from somewhere else, so
perhaps coming through
the circulatory system.
One cell may release
an endocrine signal.
It may weave its way
through the vascular system,
and then target a cell.
So endocrine is always
from a distance.
And juxtacrine is the only
one that's a little odd.
It's really from
cells that actually
are in contact with each other.
So it's not self-signaling
within a cell.
It's not a cell that's
nearby but pretty close.
It's actually physically
making a contact.
And so that's the last
terminology there.
So hopefully, I can get this
calcium wave to show you.
This is just a video of
juxtacrine to signaling.
I just want you to sort
of keep an eye on things.
It's usually a cell.
What you're observing
here is a dye
that lights up in the
presence of calcium flux.
It's called Fura-2.
And so when you stare at
these for long enough, what
you can notice is that
when one signal will often
come from an adjacent
cell right near it--
so there are long prostheses.
You're not looking
at the entire cell,
but they're definitely--
for example, this little duo
down here, they keep
signaling to each other.
And that's just a juxtacrine
signaling, because the cells
are in the contact.
So that just shows you
the difference there.
If it was autocrine, you just
have a single cell responding.
If it's paracrine, they would
be at more of a distance
to each other.
I hope that imagery-- this is
from a website in the Smith Lab
at Stanford.
OK.
And then the last thing I
want to give you an example,
there are many, many
hormones in the body that
undergo endocrine signaling,
and so one example I thought
I would tell you about,
you all know that insulin
is made in the pancreas.
It's an important hormone for
regulating glucose levels.
And it's actually-- functions
at the muscle level.
So insulin is an example
of an endocrine signal,
because it travels a
distance from where
it's made in the body to where
it functions in the body.
All right.
Now-- so we've talked
about the types of signals.
Let's now move to the
types of receptors.
Now, we cover both
the intracellular
and the cell surface receptors.
But we really will focus a lot
on the cell surface receptors.
I just want to give you a
clue that not all signaling is
cell surface.
So what I've shown
you here is a cartoon
where you see signaling,
where a signal
comes from outside the cell.
It goes into the cell
and triggers a change.
And then the
majority of the time
we'll talk about
these receptors that
are in the plasma membrane.
And they have an outside
place where the signal binds,
and they trigger
a response inside.
And it's only very
specific signals
that are able to
signal intracellularly,
that is, to cross the membrane
to get inside the cytoplasm
to do the triggering.
What kinds of molecules can
cross the membrane easily?
We talked about
that before, when
we talked about getting
across that barrier.
Yeah?
Nonpolar.
OK.
So you can look at a-- you
can stare at a molecule,
and if it's very
polar or pretty large,
it's not going to be able
to sneak through a membrane.
So something like
a steroid molecule,
a large, greasy
molecule, can definitely
make that transition.
And so those are the only types
of signals that we can really
do inside the cell, because
they can get across the cell.
Many, many other signals
have to go through this--
bind to the outside of a
cell, and transduce a signal
to the inside of the cell.
So one very typical signal that
can bind to an intracellular
receptor is a steroid.
So remember when I talked to you
about these lipidic molecules,
things like testosterone
and cortisol.
These are very
hydrophobic molecules.
So they literally can cross
from the outside of the cell
without a transporter.
So for example, the
hormone cortisol.
And when that
functions, it just--
an amount of it
becomes available,
for example, in the bloodstream.
It crosses the
cell, and it binds
to an intracellular receptor.
Once it binds to that
intracellular receptor,
this disengages a different
kind of chaperone protein
that's keeping it stable.
Once it's found, it can then
go into the nucleus and trigger
transcription.
So this is the one example
of an intracellular receptor
that we'll talk about.
I just wanted to
show you a little bit
about the steroid receptors.
These are molecules
that are very--
these are macromolecules,
proteins that are very--
quite a complex structure.
But they can literally-- and
I'll show you the picture
at the beginning of
the talk next time--
they can literally
engulf these proteins.
So once the steroid
is bound to that,
it completely changes shape.
And that's what enables
the change for it
to be triggered and
sent to the nucleus.
Now, the key types of receptors
that we'll focus on, though,
are the cell surface receptors.
And there are
three basic classes
of molecules that occur in
the plasma membrane that
are critical for
cellular signaling.
They are the G
protein-coupled receptors,
the receptor tyrosine
kinases, and then
you will talk in the lecture
22 about ion channels,
and how they perform
a receptor function.
So the membrane
proteins, first of all,
I want to underscore
their importance.
50%-- they comprise
50% of drug targets,
the receptor tyrosine kinases
and the G protein-coupled
receptors.
The G protein-coupled receptors
have this 7 transmembrane helix
structure, which
spans a membrane.
This would be the
outside of the cell,
and the inside of the
cells-- so there's
signals going across there.
The receptor tyrosine kinases
are another important type
of receptor.
They are dimeric proteins
that in the presence
of a ligand dimerize, and then
cause intracellular signaling.
Once again, they cross
the plasma membrane
from the outside to the cytosol.
And then lastly, there are
the ion channels, which also
may cross the plasma membrane.
And when you think about
these classes of proteins,
there's a tremendous amount
to be learned with respect
to their functions.
And they are so
important to understand
their physical
functions in the body,
because they really represent
the place, the nexus, where
signaling happens in the cell.
So I want to briefly show
you a picture of a GPCR.
It's a 7 transmembrane
helix structure.
You can see it here.
There are about 30% of
modern drugs actually target
the GPCRs.
And here, I'm just going to show
you the structure of a GPCR.
Those are the 7
transmembrane helices.
If you stretch them out, that's
about the width of a membrane.
That's typical of
a signal that would
bind to that kind of receptor.
This is a chemokine.
It's a small protein receptor.
So you can see that
structure and how
it would go from one side of
the membrane to the other.
In it's bound
state, the chemokine
binds to the 7
transmembrane helix receptor
through kind of a
clamping action.
The magenta is the chemokine.
The blue and the green space
filled parts are actually
what holds the chemokine.
And if you look at it where
the membrane would be,
you can see how
you can transduce
a signal from one side of
the membrane to the other,
by the binding of
the magenta molecule
to the outside of the cell, to
those loops outside the cell.
That would have a
significant perturbation
to the biology and chemistry of
what's going on on the inside.
So next class, we'll
talk about pathways
that are initiated by these
G protein-coupled receptors,
and what that terminology means.
OK.